from original cast members to newcomers
like Cali Hobart and ren DOI here's
where you've seen these that 90 show
Stars before Kurt wood Smith is back as
Eric's no-nonsense father Rhett Foreman
however this time he'll be laying down
the wall with his granddaughter Leia in
an exclusive interview with Looper Smith
expressed his excitement at returning to
the franchise and noted that he and his
on-screen wife Deborah Joe Rupp easily
fell back into step on set since red and
kitty agreed to stay in Point Place in
the finale of That 70s Show viewers were
finally able to catch up on what these
characters have been up to between 1980
and 1995 and season one of that 90s show
during the 16-year interim Smith has
added a number of film and TV credits to
his varied filmography notably the
actors starred in the second season of
Marvel's Agent Carter as Vernon Masters
a role that was written with him in mind
he then went on to guest star on a
handful of popular series like suits and
Jupiter's Legacy before having a role on
the Hulu miniseries the Dropout Smith
plays David boyes in the Amanda
cyprid-led biographical crime drama
which was nominated for six Primetime
Emmy Awards fans of that 70s Show might
have also noticed him playing old man
Peterson in the ranch another Netflix
comedy led by co-star Ashton Kutcher
joining red for the difficult task of
keeping Leia in line is his wife Kitty
Deborah Joe Robb reprises her role as
the fan favorite character who's best
known for being something of a mother
figure to all of Eric's friends Rupp
continued to work on family-oriented
shows when That 70s Show wrapped taking
roles in shows like better with you this
is us and I feel bad rupp's extensive TV
credits also include guest stints on
other popular series like Heart of Dixie
and Gray's Anatomy in 2021 she joined
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as a
series regular in Wanda Vision the first
installment of Marvel space 4. that 90s
show viewers might recognize Rupp and
her role as Westview citizen Sharon
Davis aka Mrs Hart speaking about her
role in the miniseries Rob told Looper
in an exclusive interview that her
sitcom and theater background is really
what sealed the deal on her getting
apart although she was initially
hesitant Rupp loved being a part of One
Division saying because I am as old as I
am it just was really nice to look
around and go oh I remember a TV like
that oh I remember that rug those things
are fascinating to me especially when
they're well done and the production
values in this were great you did feel
like you were in that world it was easy
we had such a lovely time the first and
most important addition to the new cast
of that 90s show is Cali Harvard who
takes on the role of Eric and Donna's
teenage daughter Leia Texas native
havarda has been acting since she was
six years old telling her High School
paper the Westwood Horizon in a 2022
interview my parents actually wouldn't
let me start acting until I was old
enough to decide I wanted to do it for
myself I practically begged them to let
me do a commercial my siblings agent
submitted before they let me and I just
fell in love with it from there however
does best known for her role is Lala
marks in the Hulu crime drama shut eye
in 2017. that 90s show is undoubtedly
Howard's biggest role to date though and
a defining moment in the actor's career
she told the Horizon that her career
previously lacked Direction and finding
Leia's character sparked something in
her saying I fell in love with it and
truly connected with the work as a whole
that 90s show is all about Leia
connecting with wrong group of friends
beginning with the rebellious Riot Girl
Gwen played by Ashley offter Hyde Gwen
is Leia's next door neighbor and the two
hit it off immediately in fact Gwen
literally lives in Donna's old house
since Bob pinciotti moved to Florida at
the beginning of the 80s
he found the people who don't fit in
and I am their Queen
prior to joining the cast after Hyde's
biggest roles included ABC sci-fi
mystery drama and Merchants an indie
flake infinitely polar bear which stars
Mark Ruffalo and Zoe Saldana in 2020 she
also featured in the British fantasy
film for kids in it Gwen isn't the only
next door neighbor Leia gets to know she
soon befriends Gwen's fun-loving brother
Nate who's played by Maxwell AC Donovan
Nate and Gwen have an interesting
Dynamic on the show and somewhat
replicates Eric and Laurie's
relationship since Leia is an only child
viewers might know the actor behind
Nate's big smile from his starring role
in the Disney Channel series Gabby Duran
and the uncitables Donovan plays the
titular character Gabby's best friend
Wesley Presley and he credits A comedy
series for making his dream of an acting
career a reality prior to bagging this
long-standing main role Donovan had some
smaller supporting roles such as the TV
mini-series greenlit and the Zoe Deutsch
and Nicholas Braun LED rom-com good kids
newcomer Sam Morelos stars in that 90s
show as the ambitious and intelligent
teenager Nikki there's a lot more than
metei when it comes to Nikki deadline
described her as having quote more
Rebellion than a frustrated debutante
and her boyfriend Nate can scratch that
itch Nikki is Morello's first TV role
but she's previously starred in a couple
of short films including forgetting
nobody an extraordinary night when
filming season 1 of that 90s show
concluded Morelos took to Instagram to
celebrate the experience and everything
leading up to it alongside some behind
the scenes content she wrote
overwhelmingly grateful for the first
script the millionth script and all of
the wonderful people I met in between
takes you truly are my family Mace
Coronel plays the flirty aspiring
videographer Jay another member of
Leia's gang as well as her love interest
hey girl
with more than a decade of acting
experience behind him that 90s show
viewers will likely have seen Cornell
before you gotta start playing RJ
Forrester in The Bold and the Beautiful
before starting in the 2014 TV movie
Santa Hunters however Cornell is
probably best known for starring in
Nickelodeon's comedy series Nikki Ricky
Dicky and Dawn he played Dickie one of
the titular quadruplets of the Harper
family but he left abruptly in the
middle of production on the fourth
season he announced his departure in a
since deleted Instagram post which
explained that it was a mutual decision
so he could focus on other roles as
promised Coronel Diversified his
filmography and he went on to star in
short films and some miniseries he said
on his Instagram that he hoped the 2019
short film pocket which is a commentary
on social media and having the world in
your pockets would be an eye-opening
film for audiences he followed this up
with roles and wireless and Colin
Kaepernick and Ava duvernay's drama
Colin in black and white as beloved as
That 70s Show is parts of it wouldn't be
accepted today and that includes its
lack of lgbtq characters and storylines
while the short-lived spin-off that 80
show had a bisexual character Ren DOI
will play the TV franchise's first
openly gay character Ozzy though he's
been acting since 2017 bagging his first
job as a dancer in a Sonos commercial he
quickly racked up a number of credits
and commercials and short films before
playing Takeshi the son of an extradited
fugitive in an episode of the crime
action series SWAT in 2020. his big
breakout role came the following year
though when he played yo-yo and Barb and
star go to Vista Del Mar he plays
Kristen wiig's sidekick but is the New
York Post notes DOI quickly steals the
show at the same time DOI was working on
the Nickelodeon family comedy side
hustle and the TV movie adopted actor
and musician Olivia sanabia has a
supporting role in that 90s show with
Serena she is best known for starring in
the Amazon Studio series just add Magic
from 2016 to 2019 in which she plays
Kelly Quinn in 51 of the show's 52
episodes while filming the third season
of the magical dramedy sanabia started
working on the Disney Channel series
Coop and cameos the world when that show
ended she bagged guest roles in a
variety of other notable series you
might reckon as Luanne in country
Comfort McKenna and this is us and Haley
from Colin in black and white viewers
may also know sanabia as a singer her
discography includes three original
singles Star-Crossed Evergreen and the
Train the latter of which is a
particularly important message about
accepting your differences sanabia
explained in a 2020 interview with girls
live you don't have to jump on the
bandwagon with everyone else you don't
have to like the same things or do the
same things tougher Grace was the
leading man in That 70s Show before he
departed ahead of season 8 to star in
Spider-Man 3. he did however return for
the series finale and conclude his story
by getting back together with Donna
Grace's early exit is one of the sore
points of That 70s Show and to add
insult to injury Spider-Man 3 was
largely panned with director Sam Raimi
even calling the film awful I'm gonna
put some dirt in your eye
thank you
it somewhat put the brakes on Grace's
Rising Star but he has since gone on to
enjoy big movie success since the 2007
superhero film Grace has starred in a
handful of notable features like
Interstellar American Ultra War Machine
delirium and black klansmen he's also
found a permanent home on the TV comedy
home economics which follows Grace's Tom
the oldest of three siblings who are all
in different Financial situations
speaking of family shows returning to
the world of Point Place again for that
90s show felt like a family reunion for
Grace he told E.T it was like going home
for Christmas to see your whole family
to be able to go back and not just hang
out with them together which was so much
fun but then to be able to work again
with them it was great that 90s show had
a lot of work to do to connect the dots
between the finale of That 70s Show in
1995. including Donna's story of raising
Leia and becoming a writer or a pre-pawn
certainly believes it does her character
Justice telling US Weekly before season
1 was released I can't wait for people
to see it I think they're really really
gonna get a kick out of it Donna has
clearly been busy over the last decade
and a half and so is pre-pawn after
playing the red-haired tomboy for eight
years pre-pawn took on the lead role in
the NBC sitcom are you there Chelsea of
course that 90s show viewers probably
know her best from her long stint as the
dark-haired Maven Alex falls and Orange
is the New Black while filming the
comedy drama Prepon also appeared as
Kathy in the 2016 psychological Thriller
the girl on the train with Eric and
Donna coming back why not try to get as
much of the whole gang back together as
possible Mila Kunis confirmed her return
to the franchise as Jackie Burkhart in
an interview with Access Hollywood where
she explained the different relationship
Dynamics which have taken place off
screen since the finale although Jackie
and Wilmer valderrama's character Fez
were together when the series ended
everyone knew she was meant to end up
with her husband Ashton Kutcher's
character Kelso before season one even
came out the actor let slip a few
details about her part in the upcoming
series concluding the fact that Jackie
and Kelso are now married with a kid
since 2006 Kunis has starred in a string
of movies she's been in romantic
comedies like Forgetting Sarah Marshall
and friends with benefit kids she's been
in action comedies like The Spy Who
dumped me and romantic action adventure
films like Jupiter Ascending she's also
been in more dramatic features like the
Academy award-nominated film Black Swan
in 2022's luckiest girl alive as well as
this Kunis has voiced the character of
Meg Griffin in Family Guy since season 2
in 1999. that 90s show is one of only a
few times she shared the screen with
Kutcher since the original series Kunis
said of returning to the show with
Kutcher it's very cute it was weird to
shoot together though Ashton Kutcher
credits That 70s Show with kick-starting
his career and told Variety in a 2022
interview that the reason he and his
wife Mila Kunis are returning for the
spin-off is so that they can pay homage
to that he said we just went back and
had fun for a week it was so random and
fun in the Years between the original
series and that 90s show Couture has
enjoyed a very successful film and
television career viewers will no doubt
recognize him from one of his roles in
romantic comedy films such as what
happens in Vegas Valentine's Day Killers
and no strings attached from 2011 to
2015 Kutcher also starred in The Beloved
comedy series Two and a Half Men
replacing Lee Charlie Sheen while
speaking on the WTF with Marc Maron
podcast Kutcher explains that he owes
much of his comedic success to That 70s
Show creator Bonnie Turner who taught
him to quote rhythms of Comedy from 2016
to 2020 Kutcher focused on TV namely his
role as Colt Bennett and Netflix's
family dromedy the ranch Kutcher has
since returned to Features starring in
the 2022 black comedy Vengeance
alongside BJ Novak Boyd Holbrook Isa Rae
Dove Cameron and John Mayer Wilmer
Valderrama is best known for playing
foreign exchange student Fez in all
eight seasons of That 70s Show since it
ended Valderrama has been the architect
of his career intentionally choosing
varied projects in different genres to
work on some of his notable credits
include From Prada to Nada From Dusk
till Dawn the series Minority Report and
NCIS speaking to people in 2022
bellarama explained the responsibility
he felt during the early stages of his
career as a Latino actor he shared I
started really paying attention to the
roles I was portraying to the things I
was saying yes to and to what artistic
demonstration of our culture was I
actually amplifying by showing up to
whatever movie and character I chose but
I do need you to lower that weapon
please and thank you
fans may also recognize Valderrama from
his recurring role in The Ranch in which
he plays Humberto in his five episode
guest stint on Gray's Anatomy as patient
Kyle Diaz however That 70s Show still
holds a big place in his heart in fact
according to the Wall Street Journal
Valderrama still owns the original Vista
Cruiser from the series when she
purchased for 500 although that 90s show
reveals that Fez didn't end up with
Jackie because of her feelings for Kelso
things are looking up for the owner of
his successful Salon chain hopefully his
new flame Andrea Anders character Sherry
and him can make it work in the long run
That 70s Show Alum Don Stark is also
returning for the spin-off and a
supporting role as Donna's dad Bob
pincione speaking about his return to
the set with Entertainment Weekly Stark
said it was amazing it really brought
back a flood of wonderful memories all
the young people who were in the new
cast were terrific and it mirrored what
it was like when we started viewers will
of course know that Stark is not
returning with his on-screen wife Tanya
Roberts who sadly passed away in 2021
however his return in episode 6 of
season 1 is a delight especially his
karaoke performance at his granddaughter
daughter's birthday party since 2006
Stark has been busy guest starring on a
variety of TV series his knack for
comedy has helped him secure roles in
the likes of Curb Your Enthusiasm
Shameless and doll face he's also used
his comedic acting chops to play Jules
padell in 2018's green book and Saul and
the star-studded rom-com cafe Society
actor comedian and musician Tommy Chong
will forever be known to That 70s Show
fan says veteran turned hippie Stoner
Leo the Beloved member of the Cheech and
Chong comedy duo was an important member
of the show's Supporting Cast although
he wasn't present in every season he
often showed up just in time to make
some interesting observations relating
to the lives of Eric and his friends he
also took hide under his wing giving him
a job at the photo Hut that 90s show
just wouldn't be complete without an
appearance from Leo but thankfully Chong
has returned and made a fitting comeback
in fact he hilariously doesn't seem to
pick up on many of the callbacks to That
70s Show or even remember Kitty in red
since the original series ended in 2006
Chong has been a vocal marijuana
activist alongside his 2006 documentary
AKA Tommy Chong which Chronicles this
the actor often plays activists or
characters who use drugs freely just
like Leo more recently Chong played
Stoner Hubert Wilson in the racing Hope
season 4 episode the one where they get
high viewers might also recognize Chong
from his appearance on the Masked Singer
in 2019 where he competed on the reality
singing show as a pineapple